One I went to the billboard music awards this weekend. Two I have not washed my hair since I went to the billboard music awards
This weekend three you can very obviously tell that
Hello guys. My name is Grace Helbig if you did not know now. You know your life is different now
You already know what this video is because the title says what it is and you can read
this is the billboard music awards Fashion review yes, I did go to the billboard music awards they invited [me] because [I]
personify Music culture
You can hear a little bit more about my experience at the billboard music awards
And how I got ready [cuz] I did my own hair makeup and i wore fabrics on my blog
I have blog in fact I have an entire website of things including a blog gracehelbig.com
check it out
or don't [I] know I know I am so
music
Fergie wasn't there
So let's start reviewing these red carpet fashion Shall we yes Demi Lovato Demi lovato
Always looks sangry sexy angry she looks like she just clocked in for work
And don't fuck with me incorporated
I think she looks great because she looks great and also because I don't want her to fuck with me cute
Ariana Grande you look like the sexy inside [of] a computer
I'm dialed up your wi-Fi is strong cuz I'm [surfing] boner calm webmd more like web m damn
She's something for that webmd
Dick just kidding what sorry [when] someone looks good. I turn into insecure frat boy
It's a medical thing maybe I should web m dick it.  Lucy hale
You look like a sexy russian ice dancer on top and a too sexy
Funeral goer on the bottom very interesting combo [I] give you tens
I'm sure a couple [Tonya] [hard-on] showed up to you
Why am I being Kelly Rowland you look like the Elsa to?
Ariana Grande's the other one from frozen
I hope your wi-Fi strong enough to google these refrences. zendaya
How do you pronounce your name here? We go? How do you pronounce  Zendaya?
zen day uh
you don't be so
judgy about it and zendya at the event and I
Did this I couldn't form words or sentences?
And just look I just stared directly I just blatantly and Openly and honestly
With all my body, and I just stared at her because she looked so beautiful
Honestly, she looked even more beautiful in person is it possible then?
She look great Ashton Kutcher [looks] like he's going to the sexy Civil war
sexy chimney sweep sexy character from the Broadway musical rent sexy adult orphan
He's given a lot of looks and I appreciate the variety I also appreciate
Tucking your pants into your boots because you don't know when you'll encounter snakes Meghan trainor. She looked so good
[she] looks like the sparkly version of like when you're old computers used to freeze and then an hourglass would come up and be all
Like no, and usually you're like no, but this sparkly version. I'm like yeah, I can wait cute, Rihanna
You look great
You look a little bit like a sexy 80s female stoned comedian and a little bit like sexy elaine from Seinfeld [and] a little bit
Like sexy Inspector Gadget Cosplay, and I don't hate any of it. She don't need no man
she dont need no pants. Jessoca alba. You look like a
thing
You look like the good girl that let the bad girls give her a hot topic makeover Heidi Klum
[you] look like Heidi. Klum it. Just looks like it's trying to get off of your body every way possible
But you look pretty [kesha]. I love this look this is an homage to Bob Dylan and prints and oh my
I want that too. You look like a sexy, but approachable matador. I'm into it dance or DNCE
What is it DNCE. pronounced DNCE
pronounced DNCE.
I think you guys look like you were the most eager people at the pep Rally until a
Giant Fire started at the pep Rally you still showed up for the game, and that's that's real guts
Good for you fifth harmony. [this] is the best funeral I've ever been to wiz Khalifa me app
I wish god [Dammit]
I wish [that] [was] me not like the life
But just that style the other Jonas looks like the other Jonas. Can boys get camel toe?
Mmm is happening in South America one girl often translations out there, britney spears
What?
You look great you took all the bits on [the] workroom for project runway?
And you made them work you also somehow got a curtain stuck in your butt on the way out the door and that works
Too I love it. Love it. Love it. Shawn Mendes like I said this is the best funeral. I think I've ever attended Laverne Cox
Halsey. 1 she should be my friend. [-] you look like an ish your pending [that] I'm okay being lost in Pete Wentz
Yeah, dude
Michael Strahan doing the best he stra-can. Lindsey sterling look at this angel sent from
Heaven. you look classy look sexy. You look mermaidy. You look gorgeous
God [dammit] seal looks like a [six-year-old] boy that tried on all of his dads clothes
And is not self-aware enough to know [that] they don't fit Priyanka. [you] just look so pretty now laptop bag strap around your neck?
That is very
Millennial Steven Tyler I
Just I want what I won't. I want. I want to be. I want one people when they see me to see that
My camera shut off which is probably for [the] best. I think I was malfunctioning. [Troye] sivan
Like it [boo]. [boo]. Look at this look at this and look at this pleated pants on the silk
How dare you make what every skeezy guy [in] the 90s in Miami wore look adorable?
There you go there my thoughts on the billboard music awards Fuchsia Carpet fashions everyone looked
Alive [I]
Know I didn't cover everyone that you might want to be - that was on the future carpet, and I'm sorry
but there's just too many people to talk about if you want to hear more about my look go over to my blog for a
Selfie comm check it out and don't forget to subscribe if you enjoy these videos
He's got button right [there], and then we can be connected. I'm getting closer and closer to 3 million subscribers and I
Just really want to pass it let me know who your favorites add the billboard music awards and I
don't know see la La this looks like
this looks like